launching operation warm welcome the way
by which we're going to well look after
uh those afghans that looked after us in
afghanistan just tell us a bit more
about it
very much so well over the last two
weeks alone we've evacuated some 15 000
people to our country and of course
since april we've evacuated more people
who have done right by us they're the
people who on the ground over the last
20 years have been working with our
soldiers helping to protect them helping
to translate helping to make our
embassies and other areas work and so
the prime minister's commitment is
absolutely clear to this um they have
done right by us we want to do right by
them and so today i'm delighted that
we're launching operation warm welcome
to give a warm welcome to everyone who
has landed on our shores in recent weeks
but in the longer term as well
and make sure that with us with our help
they can build bright futures in our
country
of course the the the option to have
indefinite leave to romania will be
grabbing everyone's attention but
there's also a lot more assistance for
those that have arrived under rare up as
well
very much so so um we uh have to today
announced uh indefinite leave to remain
as you say which is important because it
means that they have for example rights
to work and so many of the people that
we've been watching our television
screens over the last few days have
expressed the wish to give back to the
uk once they're settled here with their
families but we also want people to
integrate you know this has got to be
fair to the british people as well as to
our new afghan neighbors and friends and
so we are
setting out plans to help
adults and those who don't speak english
to learn our language so that they can
contribute fully to our society and also
importantly educating those children
their children have witnessed the most
traumatic scenes in recent weeks and we
want to get those children into our
schooling system uh with the right help
the right support so that again we're
building positive futures for them and
so we're announcing 12 million pounds to
support that education effort we're also
conscious of course as well that there
will be some very severe medical needs
again some of the trauma that people
will have witnessed and experienced we
must confront we must deal with and so
we're announcing a further 3 million
pounds to help with the health care
needs of people
and in addition of course everybody
needs homes and so there's a long-term
piece of work to ensure that we're able
to provide homes for people who have
come to our country
administers all of this applies to those
who who have come here and will continue
to come here under the afghan relocation
and assistance program what about those
who will be coming here under under the
resettlement scheme will they be
afforded and definitely to remain as
well
well we're very much working on this
scheme at the moment um you'll
appreciate that this is uh it's a huge
task ahead of us um and we want to get
it right and look we've done this before
because we've done this with the syrian
resettlement programme
and that has been widely been judged to
be a success and so we want to take the
very best parts of that scheme to build
this new scheme to help those who are
vulnerable within afghanistan those who
may have espoused western values who may
have stood up for women's rights for
example as well but just but just
sorry it's interesting because we've got
finite time but just in terms of we have
already subject we've already suggested
that we will be taking 5 000 people
separately under the resettlement scheme
this year alone
when they get here has it been decided
yet whether or not they will be allowed
to be granted indefinitely to remain
as i say please don't read anything into
it other than we're just working on it
at the moment as i said you this is a
very very um fast-paced very very large
task
and i've got 10 000 people um staying in
quarantine hotels today for example
we've got to make plans for the bridging
accommodation that they move into once
they're released from quarantine so um
these decisions will be made in due
course but i very much hope that from
the announcements today
uh
british people but also importantly uh
afghans who have moved to our country
very recently really get the sense of
how warm and welcoming the government
wants to be towards them and indeed this
is reflected in the response of british
people themselves uh we've seen over the
last few days how generous people have
been
i know
for example people turned up to the
hotel where afghans are staying with
toys with nappies with clothes
trying to do their best to to help and
and i we want to very much take
advantage and seize every opportunity of
kindness that people are able to offer
and
we're developing at the moment a portal
that people will be able to log on to to
uh register how they can hope to help uh
afghan friends moving into their area in
indeed but but of course you know time
is in essence of the essence for those
who remain in afghanistan at the moment
we know from speaking to the foreign
secretary yesterday that at least
several hundred low hundreds but several
hundred you know british nationals
remain in afghanistan there are also
thousands of others who may have been
able to qualify for anap or may have
been able to qualify for the
resettlement scheme and at the moment
the advice seems to be
get to the border get over the border
what happens after that point how can
they then make their way to the united
kingdom or indeed to is there a
processing center we've heard that
talked about a number of times
yeah so um the foreign office as the
foreign secretary set out yesterday the
foreign office are in uh intense
discussions with third countries in the
region
because we want to make sure that if
people are coming to the border which
they will be um that those third
countries are able to deal fairly and
efficiently with those people and so
we're very much in discussions with them
of course part of this
is um ensuring that the taliban
do what the u.n security council
resolution requires them to do namely to
offer safe passage to people who are
rightly traveling to the borders to um
uh to seek sanctuary and what do we do
what how far are we prepared to go with
the taliban if they renege on promises
that they they have already made in
terms of safe passage
so simon gas uh has it's been announced
overnight simon gas the prime minister's
representative on afghan uh resettlement
is um very special envoy is very much uh
there in doha at the moment discussing
with senior taliban figures
on the future and i i don't want to in
any way uh impinge on those discussions
but the international community is
watching very closely what the taliban
is doing and will do over the next uh
weeks and months
and the foreign secretary and others
have been clear that we will use every
lever at our disposal diplomatic and
otherwise to ensure that the taliban
lives up to the resolution that was
passed by the security council
as as mentioned before of course those
relocating here under arab they have the
afghan relocation program i mean they
they are people who have assisted us you
know in our fight in afghanistan and and
their families and and people will not
begrudge them
being helped when they reach this
country but but do you not accept
that you have in essence now created
another tier another class perhaps
within our immigration and asylum system
well i don't think anyone watching the
scenes that we've seen over the last
couple of weeks could have failed to
have been moved by the
terror the desperation the anguish the
fear that people
were experiencing
not just outside the gates of the
airport but also of course across the
country and so i very much and i have
complete confidence that as you say uh
british people will understand that and
will want to respond and insurance but
do you do you accept that that they are
going to be treated differently by the
immigration and asylum program to anyone
else
well we have already the model for this
with the syrian resettlement scheme uh
as i say you know that was set up in
2015 um that we went to great efforts to
ensure that accommodation and other
services were already set up uh in
advance of syrians being lifted from
refugee camps to come to this country
for safe sanctuary um
these circumstances are obviously pretty
different not least because we've had to
evacuate people at such a fast pace into
the uk
but i would hope that given the um
the effort the work that
these translators these security guards
these
afghan army
members have done for us over the last
two decades the british soldiers they
will have worked with the lives
potentially some of them will have saved
um i'm very much hoping that we'll be
able to as i say do right by them just
as they did right by us just very
specifically on on the re-housing of
those who are coming here
do we do we really have the capacity to
re-home what 20 000 plus
afghans over the next five years when we
heard from local government association
chairman james jameson earlier you know
the nature of the refugees we're seeing
significantly larger families housing
stock as you well know is at a premium
in every part of the country
particularly when we get to the larger
sizes and we're we're kind of giving
five million top up payment to local
authorities that's not going to quite
cover it alone is it
look i want to be straight with people
this is a very very difficult challenge
and we are very very aware that of the
pressures on the housing market and
housing
lists already that is why
we have announced this as you say top-up
fund to help councils find larger
properties for
afghan families but it comes back to
integration again
this policy will succeed if we welcome
and we integrate people into our
societies and we get them settled into
accommodation help their children get
into schools get them registered at gps
and so on and then they can begin to
pay back into our society and i've heard
some wonderful stories over the last few
days you know people who have fought
with the british army have translated
for the british army determined uh when
they can to if they're allowed to join
the british army
others who very much want to
study so that they can continue their
medical careers and so on there have
been some really really inspirational um
stories that uh we've heard from people
who have
and so we really really want to achieve
that
i just want to squeeze in just a just a
just a kind of a final comment of course
afghans fleeing the country will be
trying to get to different parts of the
world for safety by a variety of means
we understand of course from this
government that in future you are
seeking
to deny asylum to people who arrive in
the uk having passed through other safe
countries it would seem that at some
point they're not too distant future
there will be hundreds if not thousands
of afghans who have made their way
through safe countries coming to the uk
and trying to claim asylum will we truly
deny them asylum at that point because
they have passed through safe countries
we are absolutely determined to crack
down on the illegal people trafficking
gangs that we see exploiting the channel
exploiting people um for profit it is
incredibly dangerous for people to make
these journeys i mean i my previous
career i used to prosecute criminals for
a living and and uh some of the cr the
migration cases i saw at the time were
truly truly horrific and so we want to
stop that um and we've got to send this
very clear message out to the people
traffickers
that if they do this if they're caught
then they will be dealt with in our
justice system
and when you just just to underline how
dangerous it is i mean very recently uh
someone sadly died in the channel trying
to make their journey across so this is
why
as part of this package we're saying
look we won't put up with illegal
immigration but please please use safe
and legal routes and that's why the
afghan resettlement scheme is so
important and taking you know what
little time we've taken to set it up
properly is vital because we want to
help people
who you know should come to this country
want to help them come here legally and
safely as indeed we did with the syrian
resettlement scheme